imaginemos que vamos a lanzar un objeto
al aire con cierto ángulo digamos que su
rapidez es ese y el ángulo con el que
estamos lanzando lo el ángulo con
respecto a la horizontal es teta lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es calcular
qué tan lejos va a llegar este objeto
como una función del ángulo y también
como una función de la rapidez pero
vamos a suponer que nos están dando
estas rapidez
este es el suelo si este es el suelo
queremos encontrar qué tan lejos llegó
el objeto y podemos imaginarnos que va a
viajar en una ruta parabólica y va a
caer en algún lugar más adelante
si esta es la distancia cero llamaremos
a este punto nuestra distancia de y
siempre que resuelvan algún problema
como este cuando está lanzando algo con
cierto ángulo lo mejor que puedan hacer
desde el principio es descomponer este
vector en sus elementos horizontal y
vertical recordemos que un vector es
algo que tiene magnitud y dirección la
magnitud va a ser s nuestra rapidez
quizás en metros por segundo o
kilómetros por hora y la dirección es el
ángulo theta así que si tenemos ese y
theta tendremos un vector y lo que
quieren hacer es descomponer este vector
en sus componentes horizontal y vertical
y después analizar cada uno de estos por
separado uno para calcular cuánto tiempo
estuvimos en el aire y el otro para
encontrar qué tan lejos llegamos voy a
dibujar una versión más grande de este
vector aquí nuevamente la magnitud de
este vector es ese y este ángulo de aquí
es teta para descomponer este vector en
sus elementos horizontales y verticales
tenemos que dibujar un triángulo
rectángulo para usar nuestras funciones
trigonométricas básicas esta parte es el
suelo y dibujo una línea vertical a
partir de la punta de la flecha de la
y aquí tenemos nuestro triángulo
rectángulo y la magnitud del componente
vertical de nuestra rapidez es esta
longitud de acá que voy a llamar sb y
esta parte horizontal del triángulo
puede llamarle el componente horizontal
de nuestra rapidez s h y ahora tenemos
un triángulo rectángulo la rapidez es la
hipotenusa y podemos escribir nuestro
soca tohá para recordar nuestras
funciones trigonométricas esto nos ayuda
a recordar que el seno es igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa que
el cocina es igual al cateto adyacente
entre la hipotenusa y finalmente que la
tangente es igual al cateto opuesto
entre el cateto adyacente por eso eso
kato a cuál será nuestro componente
vertical pues este componente vertical
es opuesto a nuestro ángulo y sabemos
que la hipotenusa es ese viendo nuestras
funciones trigonométricas aquellas que
relacionan el cateto opuesto con la
hipotenusa es el seno vamos a usarlo y
nos dice que el seno detecta es igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa el
cateto opuesto es sdb y nuestra
hipotenusa ss
efe
entre ese y como queremos encontrar sb
vamos a multiplicar ambos lados de esta
ecuación por efe de manera que nos queda
ese por seno de teta igual a ese b
y nos va a quedar que se ve es igual a s
por seno de teta el componente vertical
de nuestra velocidad y hacemos algo
similar para nuestro componente
horizontal vemos que éste sh es el
cateto adyacente al ángulo y también
tenemos nuestra hipotenusa que es ese
así que ahora nuestra función de
econométrica a usar es coseno por lo
tanto nuestro coseno de teta
es igual al cateto adyacente sh entre la
hipotenusa s
si queremos despejar nuestro componente
horizontal vamos a multiplicar ambos
lados de la ecuación por s
nos va a quedar s por coseno de teta
igual a ese h
así que aquí tenemos nuestro componente
horizontal s x coseno de teta
y lo indicamos aquí arriba en nuestro
dibujo original y es igual a s por
coseno de teta
y encontramos que en la dirección
vertical nos queda s por seno de teta
ahora que ya hemos descompuesto a
nuestro vector podremos encontrar que
tanto tiempo estuvo nuestro proyectil en
el aire